hi I'm Charley day I'm Kayli spane I'm
John boyega I'm Scott Eastwood and
you're still burn gorman sites and we
are here to you the the 15 most googled
questions in regards to the kaiju 50s
according to mando I don't know it's
very apparent that we're gonna beat the
other team because this is rigged number
50 well is it how do you play how'd you
know Kaijudo how'd you know it's a very
tight fitting suit you each per line
that's right
wrestle on sensei the mask or you it's a
life-size why does the Pacific Rim
experienced so many earthquakes because
there's ient monsters roaming around
this is in real life yeah this is not
like something I don't know I know I'm
not going to call no idea but you know
what I wish them the best of luck yeah
48 here we go what are the Pacific Rim
countries hmm in the Pacific that's
right yes could hide you exist sure I
think there might be aliens out there
well the closest animal it would be
would be a crocodile like a mutated a
mutated croc yeah it happened yeah yeah
we don't need robust you just have to
little stubby stubby
my answer is yes see we've got a bit of
a conflict here monsters no points if ik
room to be more successful than the
original bums on seats yeah more people
go see it yeah but in the season yeah
and it wins like nine Oscars you want to
read this one
how do you pronounce kaiju okay all
right 44 everyone wants to know is Earth
or the human race prepared enough in
case of a kaiju attack this this earth
no but fortunately it's fiction all
right
can a guy from Pacific Rim beat on
Autobots from Transformers yeah
yes daggers are bigger yeah size
difference alone but in transformers to
optimus prime did bring down that big
ass one-wheeled Decepticon butts
so it's reasoning absolutely absolutely
especially if I'm in that thing I mess
up
bumblebee gonna get as well what do ya
guys eat what are you yeah gizzy yeah
high quality great canola oil what do
you guys you eat
that's a good question cuz they don't
really eat the people cod you don't eat
anything that we've heard of they they
they eat on the other side grab up
before they have alien fish 44 can
Yeager's be built they are built they
can be built they can be slim they just
can't be fat it's true alright
does Pacific Rim have subtitles HS yeah
yes we have a lot of Mandarin speaking
Japanese speakers yeah we need that yeah
yeah and then me you know my British
accent ya know anybody say what are you
girls made of highly complex cereal yes
Cap'n Crunch and metal in Pacific Rim
about how many feet tall worthy acres I
know there's a very specific answer to
this you do meters me as much I'm not 70
on me is up in here take that Charlie
for now how do you draw
Yeager's pens pencils yeah I need some
markers crayons all the game grumps
going to be in Pacific Rim
what's grumps 34 where'd you hide you
come from they come from the world of
the precursors and I Atlantic grinning
Pacific Rim related they on the same
planet that they own the same planet
32 I look odd you actually a metaphor
describing sea level rise and the
attendant risks of global climate change
I think that was an intense definitely
an attention absolutely how to draw hide
you are doing this no no no way we're
doing all right this is my moment this
is why I got into acting a little bit
more character prickly pear in it does
really good it's like a tide remix of My
Little Pony which Caillou was pregnant
it would be insensitive to pay one hour
yeah you never want to go up to kaiju be
like no sorry
Grimm have an after credit scene John oh
you know we had to yes yes it does
where to bark I'd you beer well we
filmed in Qingdao George has a very
famous beer or go round the Qingdao did
you visit what our kaiju movies is
Godzilla considered a kaiju I thought
they're related distant cousin is King
Kong I mean he's met with a kaiju
they're lizards monster I guess how'd
you means monster yep
what is kaiju combat I was like a bad
ballet yeah what is their combat it's
like stop stop
crush stump ow very cool yeah how did
hide you returned in Pacific Rim
uprising if the breach was destroyed in
Pacific Rim como well you will find out
March 23rd will you buy that ticket how
many kind you are there 11
anyway I'll card you dinosaurs
Pacific Rim how high do dinosaurs
Pacific Rim that's not a question but
they could be dinosaur card I'm about
him
very nice missing a comma is like a
kaiju dinosaurs Pacific Rim you think
we're Pacific Rim like and they're
asking all kind you yeah specific yeah
sorry how do you a guy standing water
they're waterproof they've got so much
going on well actually old Jaeger's had
to reboot when they were in water and
now our ones have propellers that take
them right back out
what is kaiju blue it's your eyes
oh it's their blood right it's blue it
stains everything yeah that's what that
is this stuff right yeah it's also a
form of depression how much would it
cost to build a Jaeger from the Pacific
Rim 1 billion dollars 1 billion no no
maintenance on that more yeah so not
affordable at all I'm not affordable at
all what about two things are stuck
together and then what's going on cuz
you think what if tide you were real
what if man what guys you were real well
what does kind you mean oh I know the
monster how a kaiju is made I mean
they're biologically put together
weaponized once I was thinking a little
well yeah I did confusing thing because
one was pregnant at the same time we do
say they were synthetically does not
sure they designed a pregnant one we can
you pick it all in it Pacific Rim
related talk about it we say yes yes
fourteen was Godzilla a kaiju I think so
I think so I mean it seems like it wets
who buy a Kaijudo card oh well you can
get your cars from tops well were they I
used to sell them in school they were
trading cards I mean they also done
Pokemon causes oh my gosh dude did you
yeah oh I would have taken full
advantage of that who are ya gir
competitors well you know musk is doing
quite well yeah Tesla you probably gotta
watch out for yeah yeah definitely watch
out for that sneaky does Pacific Rim
past the back
oh hell yeah yeah and week talked about
their life what they bid fruit tech
Jaeger tech we pause how Jiang is named
it's like you're a stripper name and as
the street or you lived on yeah how you
felt about it
how many Yeager's are there in Pacific
Rim oh I'm not gonna get the exact
number but getting close to it 9 not 21
ok well then you're like why did hide
you want new why does anyone win you I
had info well you're allowed to hell why
is what jaegerschnitzel what is a
schnitzel oh no we get messing with that
about it well that's a few more hours on
the toilet ok 6 if the government wanted
to cover up a kaiju attack on a major
city how would they go about it fake
news yeah liberal softies want you to
believe that the problem is the monster
it's the problem is we don't have enough
guns that's what they would say why
Yeager's needs 2 pilots Yeager's need 2
pilots because you actually can't
control a llego just one in these two
mines to be able to control him my
immense power unless your piloting
scrapper than your meyers got it figured
out yeah yeah what's the line a single
Niroula single new alert that's what
scrappy runs on our loot and gottlieb
drift compatible i saw some dark things
nothing with that with it but I better
pull it off what kind you are you mega
cagey yeah I'm not mega I'm that mega
let me yeah let's do it
the thing people are asking the most is
how Pacific Rim should have ended should
have ended how Pacific Rim
is the question how should ended dot dot
dot dot almost pretty happiness Helen
the number one search Google question is
what does Jaeger mean hunter hunter Oh
hmm know what I'm gonna do it free on
the for now though the question is right
yeah that was the test beat that passed
it well surely we failed in comparison
to our cast mates yeah good questions
but you don't gonna beat John and Connie
oh yeah thanks for watching guys thanks
for watching and clearly stay in school